(audience cheering and applauding)
- Have a seat.
- Hello.
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- [Kelly] Once again, y'all
are all in a music video
and I am not a part of it.
That is so cool.
I love your outfit. Nice to meet you.
- Y'all could be a tag team.
You're matchy-matchy over here.
- I know but then you've got
the gold and the black in it.
It's very nice, it all ties in.
As I mentioned, you were the first woman
to win a WrestleMania
main event. (cheering)
So can you explain- (cheering)
very excited.
Can you explain for people
that don't know what that is,
what is that?
- So, well WrestleMania, it's
like our version of the
Super Bowl, essentially.
And so for 35 years there
had never been a woman
or any women to have main
evented our Super Bowl.
And so...
(clapping, cheering)
- And they wanted it.
- And the people wanted it.
And that was the thing.
You know, it's the goal of any wrestler,
anybody who gets into the business,
they want a main event at WrestleMania.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I remember when I first,
not when I first started
but when I first got
signed to WWE I told one
of my friends, and a very
supportive friend by the way-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- that I wanted to main
event WrestleMania.
And he said, "it's nice to
have dreams, but be realistic."
And, yeah.
Which seems like, oh, gut punch.
But it was just, it was just seen
as such a far away goal that
it just wouldn't be possible.
But we made it possible!
(cheering)
And the fans made it possible.
- So tell us about the
upcoming... it's WW Rumble.
It's the Royal Rumble?
- It's the Royal Rumble.
- Royal Rumble.
I can't say Royal, Royal Rumble.
I can't, look, we found a word.
Hope it's not in a song I have to sing,
Royal Rumble.
I can't say "royal."
So what is this for everybody?
What can we expect?
- So Royal Rumble, it's the
lead up to WrestleMania.
Oh, by the way, WrestleMania
is in Los Angeles this year.
(audience cheers)
- It is, it is in Los Angeles
this year, you're right.
- So, if you happen to be
free, if anybody happens
to be free, April 1st and 2nd.
- Only if I get to body slam someone.
I'm just kidding. (Kelly laughs)
That sounds fun.
- We can always have beef Kelly.
We'll make up some beef.
Anyway-
- I like this.
- So, the Royal Rumble is
the lead up to WrestleMania.
And so what the Royal Rumble is,
it's a 30 person battle royal.
But two people start
off and every 90 seconds
a new person comes in
until we get to 30 people.
And the person who wins that throws every-
And to win you have to throw
everybody out the top rope
or you have to outlast everybody.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You have to be the last person standing
and everybody has to go-
- [Kelly] 30 people.
- over the top rope.
And then you get to stand there and point
to the WrestleMania sign.
Because there's a big WrestleMania sign.
Everybody always wants to
point to the WrestleMania sign.
And so and so that is the goal.
But it's, it's the most
it's always been my
favorite premium live event
that we've done.
And so when I was a little kid
I'd stay up till four
o'clock in the morning
back in Ireland watching it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And to be able to do it now and to have
actually been a Royal Rumble winner-
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- is beyond a dream come true.
- I love, I'm gonna talk about this
because you were saying
when you were younger,
you and your brother both,
he wanted to get into this wrestling thing
and you were too young.
And you lied about your
age right? To get in?
- I sure did. Yeah. Yeah.
- I love that most girls
lie to get into clubs,
to go dancing.
And you were like, "I'm
lying to get into wrestling."
I love it.
- Well, like I was a little,
I was a little bit of a dosser
and a little bit of a
waster and I was like...
I was 15, I was like, I need to-
- What is a dosser and
a waster? (Seal laughs)
- I knew you were going
to ask that question.
(all laugh)
- What does that mean?
You just spoke in code.
- Well you know, I'd
just be up to no good.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I was up to no good, Kelly.
- Oh, okay.
- And-
- That could be fun
- And I needed to not be up to no good.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- You know? I needed to get
in the straight and narrow.
- [Kelly] You needed some focus.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- And I thought professional wrestling
will get me on the straight and narrow.
(all laugh)
- Oh my God.
- And so I found out they were opening
this wrestling school,
down about an hour away
from where I live.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so my brother found
out and he was gonna go down
and I was like, "I wanna go down."
He's like, "you can't go down,
I don't wanna be looking
after me little sister."
And I was like, "you won't
be looking after me."
I was lying already.
(laughing)
And he said, well, you have to be 16.
I was like, "I'll lie."
And he's like, "they they
might ask you for ID."
So I was like, "all right, I'll drop it."
And so I asked my dad to drive me down
and my dad drove me down
and he dropped me off
before my brother got there
because he got the train
like a sucker.
(Laughing)
And so, and so I went
in and I said I was 17
because I thought if I
say I'm 16, they might-
- [Kelly] Very smart, clever.
- might ask me for ID.
But if I say I'm 17,
like who says they're 17
when they're supposed to be 16?
- [Kelly] Exactly, exactly.
- And it worked. I'm a genius.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And here I am.
(laughing)
- I love you so much, one
of my favorite guests.
Oh my god.
You can see Becky in the Royal Rumble,
streaming live exclusively on Peacock,
tomorrow night at 8:00 Eastern, everybody.